[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then to see what's
on the front pages
time to see what is making those
headlines with the new statesman senior
associate editor rachel kunliff and the
sons political editor harry cole great
to see both of you so let's uh check out
the front pages shall we starting with
the guardian it leads with further
criticism of the prime minister for his
comments to secure stammer about jimmy
savile after the labour leader was
confronted by angry protesters outside
the house of commons same story for the
metro the headline kier flees hate mob
and likewise the eye which proclaims
police rescue stammer from mob as the pm
faces a crunch 48 hours
well away from those troubles the prime
minister writes for the times insisting
britain will not flinch over the
possibility of conflict in ukraine
a group of northern newspapers including
the whole daily mail the liverpool echo
and the manchester evening news while
carrying the same front page pleading
with the leveling up secretary michael
gove don't leave us behind
despite concerns it could dent efforts
towards carbon neutrality the telegraph
understands six north sea oil and gas
fields could be approved this year
and the ft examines what could happen to
greek and italian borrowing costs if the
european central bank raises interest
rates
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on your screen during
the program you can check out those
front pages
while you watch us so let's bring in our
guests then rachel cundiff and harry
cole welcome to both of you um goodness
me rachel uh what happened to secure
stammer and um what was the cause of
that
it's towering stuff isn't it you showed
a very brief clip there there were
photos blurry photos in in some of the
the papers so he was caught up in what
what appears to have been a a rally or a
protest
against vaccinations and um
as as we know one conspiracy theory
often leads to another conspiracy theory
and as well as being accused of being a
traitor for his positions on on vaccines
uh
professors also made comments about
jimmy savile and protecting jimmy savile
which we can only assume is a direct
result of the prime minister making the
false claim last week that kirsten as
director of prosecutions was directly
responsible and personally responsible
for uh travel not being prosecuted at
the time now that is one false but it is
two a
conspiracy theory associated with the
far right in some very unpleasant
corners of the internet so i don't think
it's that surprising that when starmaw
was caught up in this this anti-vaxx
rally where a lot of people sadly
believe some very misleading and forced
claims about vaccines those two
conspiracy theories seem to have melded
together and created a rather terrifying
situation although reports are that he
is now back in his office safe so he was
unharmed from this which i guess the
silver lining yeah but it's led to a
series of headlines which don't make for
a for a happy start to the week for
danish once again poison johnson's
poison says the guardian metro kear
flees the hate mob the eye police rescue
stammer from the mob um and the
important thing about this i guess harry
is the reaction from people once again
in his own party
yeah the same the same half dozen names
that we've been hearing for the last
four weeks have popped up and uh and
said how outrageous boris johnson is
it's almost like a
horrible there's a slight i have a
slight unease with this story because
some of the glee in which critics
on both sides are trying to politicize
this i don't remember the same
outpouring uh of anger from labour mps
or these tory mps who have rushed to the
airwaves and rushed to their twitter
accounts when jacob reached mog or
michael gove or the bbc's nick watts or
gb news's tom harwood were caught up by
the same bunch of absolute scumbags um
they're launching around westminster
more and more they're horrible horrible
people who shout and pay down anyone
that looks vaguely like they've been
once been on television or or a popular
well-known face who's once maybe
suggested that you should get a back
scene um i think there's a there's a
slight
glee as i said in in some of this um not
least also because it's a little bit too
convenient you can't say that
uh boris johnson was taking his ideas
from the far right and then lo and
behold when the far right turn up in in
parliament and and say the same things
that suddenly all the pirates has fought
and somehow emboldened them i'm not
quite sure that's true they've been
screaming pedo defender at people uh
passing all the time is it terrible
terrible
uh
terrible situation for down street
absolutely it's an unforced own you know
error complete own goal and one that
probably it feels like about a million
years ago since you said it but it was
only a week ago that boris johnson made
those remarks it might just be probably
for the best just to knock him on the
head absolutely and that that is what
people want isn't it he's already lost
one of his most loyal advisers to that
clearly which will not have pleased him
um i think people did take seriously
didn't they you know nick what from
newsnight and a subaru another name you
didn't you didn't mention there who who
had the same sort of the brain
say it again
people have been targeted by that lot
that was a a brief uh a brief highlight
okay um so what what's the chances do
you think of the prime minister coming
back and doing a a fulsome that's not
what i meant type apology on this rachel
do you think
uh
probably quite unlikely just because
he's had so many opportunities to
clarify i mean the the speaker of the
house the day after he made those
comments sort of asked if he wanted to
withdraw them or to contextualize them
and he said no and he he doubled down
and now that
he's lost one of his closest aides
manira mirza who's been with him since
his time as as london mayor she quit
last week and her reason she said her
reason for quitting was
that exact comment i think to come back
from it now is just too much of a
of a losing face kind of um situation
and we know that boris really doesn't
like doing that when he's under fire he
tends to double down and dig his heels
in and actually um sort of go over the
top with what he said because actually
throughout most of his career people
have loved him when he when he's when
he's done that they like that show of
strength just with this particular
comment and this particular set of
circumstances that downing street is in
at the moment it doesn't seem to be
working but it does rather look like
he's backed himself into a corner
beyond that though the eye pulling apart
the relationship between
numbers 10 and 11 downey street tensions
between number 10 and the treasury grow
they say with sunak warned that he's in
danger
of being reshuffled and then the
chancellor's allies hit back at rivals
they accused of a very tiring hostile
briefing campaign this amidst this sort
of nhs recovery plan which is not yet
out as we know
yeah i mean there's lots of sniping all
around i will just make one more point
while we've got it if we are going to go
down this road of let's talk about you
know political language david lammy the
person that was involved in that was
never apologized for calling tory mp's
nazis i don't remember there being an
outpouring of
of of outrage on a similar level with
angela rainer and her tory scum comments
kirsten himself accusing the prime
minister directly being responsible for
people's deaths with the johnson variant
john mcdonald you know
the kierstadt was trying to make him
shadow of chance second try making the
chancellor two years ago and there's a
man that said that estimate they should
be lynched in the bombs and bullets of
the ira
um
you know we're a good thing so i just
think with this whole debate let's you
know step back a little bit if we are
going to have a conversation about
political language it's got to go it's
got to go both ways um on the back on
the sort of
slightly uh tedious day seven or eight
of uh uh of into cabinet civil war um i
think it's been slightly overblown the
idea that rishi sunak could be
reshuffled and boris johnson still be in
power
a month or two after that i i would be
amazed so yes look tempers fraying a bit
we saw a slightly awkward photo of the
two of them today in a kent hospital
pretending they're all fine obviously
behind the scenes things aren't that
great but crucially the cabinet and the
ministers still aren't moving against
boris johnson until he does until that
payroll vote decides
that's enough
um let's do this
then really this is he's going to sort
of limp on
on rather than be rather be ousted until
one of the cabinet put the head above
the parapet frankly um it's all it's all
kind of noise you can tell i'm kind of
slightly fed up from writing about this
stuff
too
um and harry i've done this in the wrong
order again because i was going next to
your exclusive story which is about the
new comms uh
what would you call it
newcomb's director of comms thank you
very much guitar harry who we all know
is sat in your seat to be fair uh doing
this um right what's the latest on him
because he's had an interesting day
hasn't he
very quickly first day in the office oh
sorry go rachel rachel again no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
well okay look
okay we've got about one minute so
rachel very quickly what what's he said
that's caught the attention of people
then harry you can update us with your
story
he said that the prime minister greeted
him with a rendition of i will survive
which i would love to see um because
somebody who seems to have more jobs
than george osborne gb news uh and then
lobbying on behalf of wawa and the
chinese government which i will let
harry talk about and now chief comes to
the pm interesting cv over to you harry
yeah look not a great first day uh you
would suggest he appears to have given a
welsh language interview hoping that
maybe not everyone would see it because
it was in welsh where he lifted the lid
on how he got the job with the prime
minister which included a rendition of i
will survive but more serious than that
though tonight we have leaked minutes
from a meeting in 2020 where gato hari
was representing um uh huawei the
chinese tech firm lobbying his old pal
eddie lester who used to work with with
borah johnson at city hall asking which
ministers he should nudge to get his
clients way um rather no one likes
seeing sausages made and these are
particularly
uh if you buy the sun tomorrow okay good
we will discuss that more i'm sure we
will have more time later on stay there
both of you lots more stuff to come
including mackerel and putin meeting in
moscow what could come next in ukraine
back with that in just a
[Music]
you're moment the press preview with me
now rachel connell and harry cole
welcome back to both of you um let's go
to the world's longest table shall we
harry um for the as our correspondent
described it coveted conscious russian
president it's one way of looking at it
anyway lots of high-level meetings on
ukraine um
any any optimistic signs do you think
not really i mean that is quite the
photo you
post salisbury post polonium 824
whatever it was you would suck with a
long spoon if you were going near putin
but
um i didn't think that actually
actually the kremlin that would offer up
that that image i think i mean you
couldn't get a more perfect summary of
how the west feel right now macron's
doing a bit more than most to try and
keep that dialogue open but it doesn't
seem to be going that well biden's
knight saying it's time for american
citizens to probably leave the ukraine
probably sensible doesn't like doesn't
feel like it's going well prime
minister's written for the times
tomorrow
with sort of language of we will not
flinch which doesn't um doesn't suggest
that there's been much movement liz
trust is flying to
uh flying to moscow later this week um
so i'm sure that will sort it all out
okay yep she's over her covert i'm sure
they'll check before she she'll like
she'll get the long table anyway
presumably anyway but anyway to the um
royal shakespeare company front page of
the telegraph explain rachel what this
story is about
so this is a story on the front of the
telegraph saying the royal shakespeare
company plan to
use shakespeare plays to educate
children about racism and sexism and
ableism in in the plays
because and it looked like a
spokesperson there saying the worst
thing you could do is deny that it's
there and this is on the front page of
the telegraph so i'm guessing that the
telegraph isn't going to be a huge fan
of this and is going to see this
political correctness gone mad um but
i'm a bit confused by it because i think
it's kind of impossible to read most of
shakespeare's plays and not see
the racism and and the sexism and that's
kind of what the point of studying them
is you study othello and you look at
attitudes to race you study the taming
of the shrew and you look at attitudes
to women you study the merchant of
venice and you look at attitudes to jews
this is not new so part of me wonders if
this is possibly an attempt to get in
there early uh and and ward off any
efforts to cancel shakespeare for being
sexist and racist which of course it it
is by saying no no it's educational even
though it's exactly what generations and
generations and generations of teachers
have been doing basically for the last
500 years it's interesting though yeah
rachel thank you very much need i spot
an english degree coming out there at
some point maybe
rachel's harry potter oh classy